okay welcome to spoiler corner what what
are we should we start uh Nick Fury dead
but not dead
yeah quite obviously a bit they were
advertising in the trailers Nick Fury
died sure he does I I will I will say
this though the funny thing about it
it's always fun watching movies with
people who are not really savvy to
anything like me because we got stuck
all the people behind us people behind
us they were invested in every moment of
this movie but I need to the point where
it's just like like when Nick Fury came
back made the people buddies Oh
oh my god okay he's still like he's
still I'm just like what what did you
thinks I'm like okay I'm like that's
fair like maybe you didn't read the
comments on don't realize that this is
no way you're gonna kill Nick Fury huh
but I mean Doug and I sat there we
looked at each other words like the Cure
dies and oh and they were crying behind
me yeah they're cranking I'm sick you'll
agree that Doug and I are looking into
it yeah you'll be crying in an hour when
he comes back but these two I just gotta
finish the story these people behind us
like every single little thing that
happened they would just go oh shit
oh shit she odd yeah how's the one
everybody she yeah like Nick Fury's car
gets attacked and like gets totally
blown up and it like comes out of
nowhere like the crash yeah just I just
oh yes they're the most fun to watch
this movie does it yeah I was like these
people behind us are amazing like for
this this was like this movie was made
for them yeah I mean I guess this is
like going to Disneyland there's
something for these II was like just the
most amazing thing ever and at the very
end like the one that got me the most
were two Bowens one was um when a bookie
who is the dance Waylon over to remember
to be ah be he's on the poster you see
his face yeah though the Winter Soldier
is Bucky which I'm fine with that it
just
a hard time taking any character who's
supposed to be super assessed and
seriously when his name is Bucky yeah
you could call him buck maybe we were so
lucky over hair yeah that's going bad
anyway but yeah so like he he punches
Captain America in the face like they do
the very obvious fake out like oh maybe
he'll be good it's like no he punches
Captain America amazing like the people
I said oh my god he punched it in the
face oh my god oh no he's they're really
good I'm gonna cry crying it's just so
sad they were friends I'm incredible
like this is this is the greatest gritty
whatever but the best the absolute best
was there's a moment where the the shot
set up is in such a way where Captain
America's face is like right up front
like here and then he steps aside in the
winter soldiers behind him right like
sega's right there and this is like
sting like whoosh so the second that
happens Boosh shit first don't laughing
my wife saw the film with me and she's
like kicky be like shut up but Isis can
help this is such a perfect reveal I was
like all reveals now she should have
something I thought I was gonna be there
shit I love baby they were fun so all
right let's attend the actual okay so
now Nick Fury dies I you know those fake
outs generally bother me the only thing
I'll say is it was within character and
made sense within the storyline I mean
it's the end like you yeah if he's gonna
get an assassination attempt it's better
to look dead and it's better not to tell
everybody because shield has been
compromised
third spoiler yeah um Robert Redford is
the bad guy which is so beyond obvious
here
they well we say their spoilers is now
you wouldn't be able to figure them out
yeah there buddy one person like the
people behind us yeah no way yes sir to
the movies credit if you can't figure it
out whatever it's like just it's for
that pipe most people could figure it
out oh but that's our family the movie
does not rely on the surprises it's
still even if you know the surprise you
can still enjoy it you enjoy the carrot
and this is why the movie I thought was
epic and getting back to when we send
the review I'd talk about McCoys that
was epic
I was nothing that felt like the what
I'm sorry the entire organization that
helped assemble the Avengers has been
completely compromised and is demolished
for now and was part of a conspiracy put
together by Nazis even in the picture we
have to worry about not you know honesty
or things of the villain is the little
Nazi from from the first build his mind
is in a computer and it's old silly
comic book stuff but I always buy the
way to come on you know that it's
sometimes things work better in comic
books about on the big screen because
you suddenly realize how silly they are
watching him talk in the barracks as the
computer I kind of loved that was the
one moment where I'm like okay I'm
having trouble suspending my disbelief
it's like of course and so therefore I
download it's my entire brain i Williams
and reads of electromagnetic tape in
1972 I loved it that was so traditional
comedy was but I thought they made him
kind of if you saw his face like it's a
little full whole face on the computer
with a work bus okay you only see a
little bit the eyes a little bit of the
malp it's all kind of static is it so I
felt like this is a good mix of really
silly but also kind of intimidating I
just had to laugh because when we barely
invented pong in 1972 it was atari 20
was like the atari even Aladin I did I'm
supposed to believe we can download his
brain and I'm like okay whatever but
honey it didn't wreck quit movie for me
that was the only moment though where I
was like seriously but did they just go
the one or two moments
strangely enough for me that I was
getting a little throttle denied it
works in the comics I just think when
you see it on the big screen either like
man it's only occurs in a weird
there's a one or two that sort of threw
me off a little bit was that you know
his shield that's awesome it's
indestructible and I buy it but like
he'll jump out of a building land on a
car like a whole building explodes and
rocks are falling out and they protects
him and BlackWidow with this goddamn
pizza pan somehow and none of these
rocks fall out or is that it's like it's
the one thing where I'm kind of like
okay go either make the shield bigger or
just make him uncle or something cause
the thing it's the one thing I just was
at a hard time by no you're forgetting
one key point what's that AMERICA
AMERICA AMERICA AMERICA she can't kill
murder khmer khmer she yeah um the ball
is speaking of merica the balls this
movie had yes there's a cop out they're
technically Nazis and part of the secret
organization called Hydra but let's be
honest we know what this movie is really
talking about these guys are all
neoconservative fashion douchebags well
let's talk a little bit yet that the
plan is to watch everybody 24/7
everybody everywhere everything and
through a computer predict through their
past backgrounds and checkers indeed
everything they know about you to
predict what's gonna happen in the
future and decide who's gonna be a
threat and who is it to them when they
take over yeah the one tore the test
they kill and it's legitimately creepy
by there is that like it first I'm like
oh yeah well the president you want to a
oh yeah these people but one was just
like just some dude in his backyard I'm
like dude like what the hell did he do
the game and watch yeah I sort of felt
that too like it was a very sort of Bush
I guess even kind of Obama cuz they're
still watching everybody you know having
its Tapper oh no no I think it's better
under Obama we just get more apologies
and promises that he'll look into it yes
exactly
oh that's troubling
I'm very troubled so I'm very troubled
hi Grenier he tried to kill me maybe
this wasn't I mean that this is one of
the things where I'm always sort of like
I always kind of had a feeling this is
going so it's sort of like well okay I
mean it's like it may be once hugely
surprised by this answer like well
thinking I think about how paranoid oh
yeah I thought it was I thought it was
an absolutely amazing commentary one
that I'm surprised the movie had the
balls to go through with it is pretty
obvious my place all those people would
like Bush Cheney the NSA the CIA all of
these like the Department of Homeland
Security and boom there you go like well
it but but what I like is that it's just
the right amount where you can't and
they give a mainly in superpowers yeah
so I have a min of Minority Report
reality and stuff you know but it's it
is kind of mentality where you're kind
of like you know even though I obviously
don't agree with them you know it's like
you you see where Robert Redford is
coming from you see and I even says you
know if you found out that the terrorist
was gonna kill your daughter wouldn't
you like to stop him you know before he
does would you like to yadda yadda and
it's I mean we work much better freedom
away from yes what no that's exactly and
that yeah obviously the point of movies
making but I like instead of just like
yeah we're just evil we just want
everything it's like no it's I like it
when you can sort of see what they're
talking about but obviously it's a
different they think they're completely
in the right just like many people now
think they're completely in the right
just spying on our asses 24/7 so it I
don't know I thought actually it was
really brave in at first I was almost
kind of like I felt a little bad cuz I'm
like man this movie almost went full
force with it and then it's like oh no
it's just like a bunch of Nazis held
over from World War two and it's super
secretive been like you know what the
more I think about if you want to equate
those sort of people with Nazis closest
I'm like I'll take it I said I see this
red dot on your head
hate to ruin a lovely tie I was a great
name all of a sudden like with the scale
Oh close of this band pulls up outside
my house it says flowers by I um they're
listening and the what I think because I
try think of all your spoilers but like
the one other thing I'll say and I think
I brought some better I saw the movie
there's a scene where you got I think of
the people in the shadowy rooms from
Avengers right weren't those the people
that came together at the end to like
talk with Robert Redford and stuff I
thought that was supposed to be them
like the ones I call all the big shots
and I thought that was just the shield
like head council I think there's like a
worldwide council that gives Nick Fury
his sort of myself out weren't those the
shadowy people and Avengers as well or
not really I think that's what I thought
I for watching ventures again I watched
it on blu-ray like but so this is these
people whatever in their 50-60 stuff
like that they're running everything and
stuff and they come together and the bad
guy Robert Redford's there and he's
talking about evil plan and stuff and
suddenly this woman's gotta be why do we
eat but yeah fifties is she you know
something like that suddenly just like
chicken ass and you know doing flips and
kicks and all this shit it grabs a gun
and holds it Robert Redford and everyone
the fear just goes and there's a
collective like mouthing of the words
yeah like you barely saw this one she
does all this and then she was silent
and then she takes off some sort of
digital bullshit mask and it turns out
it's Black Widow but you just know like
even though it would make no sense
whatsoever everybody the audience was
like I was really fucking hoping you was
trying to uh my wife was so like that
would have been so awesome like she was
just some ninja it would make no sex no
manners whatsoever but I always liked
some
more like Widow so I love it but there
is a party was like man that would have
been the greatest surprise ever looks
like are you somebody this guy's no I
just fucking hate you and I'm a ninja
but uh yeah no I I just thought overall
like in the depth of the story of him
having to deal with this you know again
like I keep going back I'm like this is
what Superman to me is about it if you
were going to tell the dark Superman it
should be like this him questions like
what is the American Way mean any more
can I say very then like this one really
really did it right and I managed to be
fun doing it I thought you were
mentioning you know I think we both had
our this should have been what blank was
and for you it's may I steal for me too
very much forward to cuz I'm like I like
this main character I'll I remember this
villain I remember this plan I remember
the side characters I fucking like the
side characters doing it more this is
what Iron Man 2 should have been the
prime intelligence it's so far removed
from Captain America like and it's just
like some fantasy thing but it's also
it's not something necessarily has to be
like the big and all you know man as
steel was trying to be like the big huge
you know and dart and I was trying to be
the big huge and everything like that
you know and they don't all have to be
like that in America I'm not even sure
was trying it just did it yeah well and
I think that's how you get closer to you
just sort of try to tell a good story
with good characters and stuff that's
what ends hey and yeah and I like I said
even though I don't think it's like
whatever it in my Batman or Superman
what Ellen the resolution would come
through and they actually resolved the
deal with his girlfriend from the first
movie which bumpin I like that Jimmy at
the end I'm like oh you're good I had a
date or whatever night you remember when
they move into them like I was good
moving on but what was in it for the
girls and then about yours you never see
what happens to it it's the YouTube
favorite song yeah
there is legend resolute it's a yeah
it's a good zone and I plays into the
pathos of the character like what good
casting - everybody's just so good in
this movie yeah I mean that everybody
everybody comes through well we were
having a conversation about you know we
watched Batman recently and we were
saying man the 80s had so many good side
characters I just don't think my
character actor since the car tonight
know Nolan films don't they're very kind
of bland here is some obstacle the
burden Batman so I'm not gonna get into
which one is better but the one
difference is as good as the nolan is
like everybody in an 80s movie it was
all chock-full of character yeah you
remember like everywhere like Brandon I
can quote Batman in and out because the
character actors are just so great the
bad blood and buddy
hello legs I mean it's like yeah oh yeah
all these lines remember cuz the people
were so testing there is such good
character right yeah hell even sister
addict they said like when they got the
nuns they didn't just get you know uh
background actresses they got people
that are like you know actresses that
have been and main roles and supporting
roles and stuff they didn't want just
extras you know so it was this big thing
like in 80's and 90's of really getting
this and I don't know it's like this is
something I feel like we kind of been
missing for a little bit focusing made
too much of the main characters uh but
in this one you have a lot of folks main
character and all the supporting
characters I remember like all of them
and they're all so good and they
performed so well you know even just the
smallest Rolly just they really deliver
so above the in joke - Pulp Fiction on
the gravestone oh I miss it later yeah I
thought it said the bug in the path of
the righteous it was the quote oh
brother already already the best joke
yeah no I'm almost positive that's what
it said like it that killed me like it
just got this movie was so good you know
the one thing that the last thing is
like I said we're probably uh I can't
they made more spoilers but although
credits oh yeah yeah I guess what you're
talking about
okay let's talk about that before so it
cuts to Baron von Schuch
who looks very much like Colonel Klink
yasya prabha Gandhi who bosses Boris and
not tisha or Natasha talking about some
gobble be good well let's split shield
fight it out with other people and you
no more distractions the better and they
got Loki's you know spear of
fabulousness you know with the Infinity
jam in it and then they come across two
twins and like an asshole I could not
figure out who the hell piece I did
whatever I didn't really know that in
the comic that well I I did know them
and that's why like once I've looked it
up I'm like ah looks Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch but yeah so they're
setting those two up but I guess I
didn't recognize it without like the
costumes and stuff when I want it I
guess I had to rewrite some because I'm
it right like they're gonna be I think
also in x-men Days of Future past are
they real
so I think there's gonna be other you
finally gonna cross seas over cuz guy I
wanted to see like fucking Wolverine or
x-men or somebody no no I believe it as
different actors oh I don't think
they're crossing over I so what is it
like you're whoever owns you know that
side of things
yeah that's right cuz yeah oh it's such
a shakily really yes like spider-man and
Wolverine alot seeing the Avengers it's
like we're never gonna see it damn it
run affinity war whatever big uber holy
shit storms are gonna have going and
it's like there's some deal come on to
do a Roger Rabbit just cross copyrights
or something somebody sold some of their
interest in Marvel recently I'm gonna
have to look that up I don't know if it
was fox or god only knows our audience
on post a thousand makes like here's
what it was but if one person posts it
you don't have to post it again like
just see if it's on the first page and
then don't pose for that I know he's
alone reading the Commons and twenty or
thirty people say the exact same thing
it's just look and see what's up but
yeah something just went down I don't
know if that's gonna bow one way or the
other fur but yeah I'm not sure I think
it's different actors at it since
x-men is still in its own universe okay
that's we haven't reconnected but maybe
I kind of hope that maybe they'll just
wise up and realize
No maybe we should start pooling our
resources cuz Disney and Marvel are
making you know bucket loads of money on
this and we can you know probably ride
the wave of it well I was gonna say this
might be the first I could be wrong but
the first movie that was just marvel at
me I know DC o or Disney owns it but you
know there was no Paramount there's no
dream where is it was just the marble
logo popped up in that time and see a
Disney logo - yeah yeah no there-there
was it they deem that the longer they
just have little marbles owned by Disney
and that's it I again like DC just do
something boo you oh you're getting your
ass kicked
oh but the the one the one last thing
I'll say is that because they're like I
think I'm pretty sure they announced
they're gonna do a Black Widow movie I
think lupus song was going to do it um
and I'd really like to see the one thing
I'm afraid of is that I'm so afraid that
this character is so good and but
because she's always been a side
character maybe this guy like Johansson
could put more into the performance or
maybe that made her more interesting I'm
so afraid we learned too much about her
that it's only gonna be like oh I didn't
want to know although I know it from big
things they've done it so well with
these other characters and they really
held these movies I'm so hoping that
pulls through because yeah she's just
gotten better with every movie she went
from the side character in Iron Man 2
it's like okay the tough chick whatever
to you know pretty funny in Avengers 2
holy shit this I really want see this is
Iron Man - she was just a nun I actually
was I was pissed I'm like really so why
quit was just here kick alas and leave a
that
Iron Man 2 bothers me on so many levels
is such a waste of a film but I'll bet
other ventures II was I was like okay
she was really funny still no character
I I thought she was so great in this I'm
like finally we're advancing this
character a little like I mean she was
funny in the Avengers but there's no
advancement of the character she was
funny
yeah what I like old probably well what
I like about this is she's advanced but
it's never I'm seeing this more and more
in other movies at particularly shows
like Walking Dead and stuff like they'll
evolve the character a little too much
where they'll have like these big cry
scenes for my character that when
normally
cry or have a breakdown or something but
along the sea where Captain America
comes in like cuz he just saved her ass
which was pretty clich I'm like okay
Captain America Carrie but I could've
the ripple but there's this great scene
afterwards that kind of makes up for
where she's like sitting there like
drying her hair or something after I
washed all the rubble off and he's like
are you okay
and she's like yeah fine no what's the
pink it quite this is her job well and I
like that no even cuz that falls what
she does reveal a little bit about like
in advance like like this big we BIA no
I can do her my entire career and that
sucks yeah it's totally in character and
it gives more intrigue about her past
that it's like you know I could do
before now it's like how she did and you
know they acknowledge that her past as
now been told everybody at the end
comment even she walks out of a
congressional hearing huh good her ask
me later I mean it is such yeah it is
just grown to this awesome character and
I look what's all you've done some
really fun stuff you don't some shit
though to please make this good I really
wanted a good movie guy he sound like
you're if it ends up being good that's
gonna be much like this with an MC I'm
like that's gonna be the Wonder Man the
Wonder Woman movie um yeah yeah yeah
like cuz I'm like like we got like right
now still no one woman like so ya know
it's a it it's a good flick uh go check
it out
america fuck yeah